y así es muy buenas tardes pues el voto
acaba justamente de dar que la ley ha
quedado aprobada por 347 votos a favor
151 en contra en cuanto a los puntos más
importantes estaré hay que saber esta
ley pues modifica en profundidad algunos
del azar digamos de los artículos y de
las leyes más simbólicas del derecho
francés hay que saber que uno de los
puntos que más el más fueron debatidos
fue el de la educación en casa que ahora
va a tener un bando
mucho más estricto y que para que un
niño pueda ser educado en su casa
obtenga digamos siga un curso de
educación en casa pues tendrá que ser
con el aval del ministerio de educación
no habrá algunos pasos
que van a derogar y que van a permitir
esto que sea por motivos de salud o
algún tipo de discapacidad hay dos
delitos que aparecerán ahora de ahora en
adelante en los códigos uno de ellos es
el delito de separatismo que es cuando
haya una amenaza hacia uno funcionario
del estado cinco años de cárcel hasta 75
mil euros de multa y otro que es el
delito para luchar contra el odio en la
línea esto es cuando se dice y se
difunde una información privada de
acertada una persona en que la vida de
esta persona pueda estar en peligro
hasta tres años de cárcel 45.000 euros
de multa y por último uno de los puntos
más álgidos de todo este debate y de
toda esta ley que tiene que ver con las
asociaciones de culto que saber que en
francia muchas de las congregaciones
funcionan bajo esta figura el estado
quiere más transparencia en cuanto a su
financiación en cuanto a quienes están
dirigiendo esto y sobre todo cuando se
trata de asociaciones que pueden recibir
dineros públicos